Now let's look at the solution to the first problem.
We know that we already used the forward Euler method
for both the populations of fish one and fish two.
We need to know how each population changes with time.
I've written out expressions for ḟ₁ and ḟ₂ showing the time derivatives of each population.
Now on each equation, we can see that this first term is in the form of the logistic growth function
that I showed you in the question introduction video.
We have a growth rate and then 1 minus the population over the carrying capacity
times the population again and the same thing up here.
These first terms show the positive rate of change of the population.
However, each equation also has a second part tacked onto it that shows a negative rate of change.
This expresses how each population is harvested by the fisherman.
As I said earlier, p is the fraction of the fish that we catch that are fish type two or the green fish.
We know then that the rate of harvesting
of the green type of fish is going to be p times our total harvest rate.
We can maintain the same total harvest rate if we make the coefficient in front of the harvest rate
a new equation for the red fish 1-p.
Remember we're trying to prevent the green fish from going extinct.
This means that we need to create a situation in which the rate of change
of population two is greater than or equal to zero.
If we rearrange the equation for ḟ2, which should adapt with this term,
which is showing how the population can gain fish,
should be greater than or equal to this term, which is showing how the population can lose fish.
The value of p that we're trying to calculate, however, is the exact threshold of extinction.
This is going to happen where growth exactly equals harvesting.
In other words if there are anymore harvesting or any less growth,
population two will become extinct eventually.
This graph over here like you've seen before has a blue pair of fish that shows
how the growth rate changes in population, and it also has a red curve that represents harvesting rate.
This first red line is just an example of a harvest rate, but the one that we're interested in
is this dotted red line up here, which just touches the maximum of the growth curve.
You might remember that this point on the growth curve
is also known as the maximum sustainable yield.
You can see that if we move the red line any higher, then the harvesting rate would always
succeed the growth rate and we would definitely end up with an extinct fish two population.
Similarly, if we move anywhere else on the blue line, the growth rate would again
be below this harvest rate and we will begin to deplete the population of fish two.
Right in the center, however, we have a point of semi-stable equilibrium
just like we're going to talk about in the Unit.
Any tiny bit that the population moves to the left side of the curve
will result in it eventually falling all the way down to zero,
which clearly means that fish two has become extinct.
Instead, we have slightly larger population than 5x10⁵ tons,
we will again start to see a decrease in population, and if by chance the population
has not stopped at exactly this maximum point--it will fall to the other side
of the curve and also become extinct.
Remember all this is assuming that the harvest rate is exactly at this dotted line.
Now we need to find what value of p would place the dotted line right at this position.
Again at this point we have growth rate exactly equal to harvesting rate.
I've taken the two parts of the equation for ḟ2 and written them as equal to each other right here.
We plug in the proper value for f2, which we know is 5x10⁵ ton
and we can solve using simple algebra for the threshold value of p, which equals to 0.375.
Finally looking at our code, we can see that first we've plugged in the value for p that we just calculated,
0.375, and down here in the for loop, we have a very simple translation of the equations
that we created for the growth rates of both fish one and fish two
in this box for the rate of change of either population.
So for fish one we have this and for fish two we have this.
As always, these rates of change are multiplied by h, the step size,
and added to the initial values for either fish population.
Now it's our new program and see what we get.
Here is our plots, the blue line plots the population fish that we are interested in harvesting
measured in tons and the green line plots the population of the second type of fish,
which we're trying to prevent from going extinct.
You could see that we have maintained a high level of population of the fish that we're interested in
and we've also prevented the green line from going down to zero.
You can see that as time increases, the slope of this line is approaching zero,
which means that if we plotted time going even farther out, no matter how far out
in time we decided to to plot these curves, this green line would never approach zero.
Just for fun, let's see what happens if we set p=0.5.
Well this graph looks very different from the last one that we had.
By just increasing p by the third of its former value,
we've made fish population two go extinct in just over 20 years.
Since we're harvesting more of fish two and less of fish one,
the fish one population has actually risen to a value that is higher than it was in the last part,
but we've violated our first main objective, which was to prevent fish two from going extinct.
I hope this problem has helped you submit your understanding of logistic growth,
harvesting, and equilibria.